people are feeling more burned out
and overworked than ever before
allegedly this has led to the quiet
quitting Trend wherein employees in
defiance of something called hustle
culture decide to go to work but put in
less effort everybody's talking about
quiet quitting and how it's the new
negative Talent crisis I think it's a
good thing the youngest Generations at
work are rejecting the idea of hustle
culture or framing your entire life
around some dream job they're rejecting
putting their mental health below their
performance goals and I just sort of
space out for about an hour with quiet
quitting you're doing what you're paid
for and not more doing the bare minimum
at work is not some unique quirky new
approach to life we don't need a label
for it we already had a label it's
called lazy